mr deb how did you feel when you learned
that
you were being dropped from the pirates
of the caribbean franchise captain jack
sparrow was a character that i had
built from the ground up
and
with something that i
i've
i've
of course put a lot of
my as you do with all characters but you
put a lot of yourself
into the characters so
and
also
having
worked on
these films with these people and
having added
much of myself much of my own
rewriting of the dialogue and
scenes and the
jokes and whatever they are
i didn't quite understand
how
that after that long relationship and
quite a successful
relationship certainly for disney
um
that
they would
that suddenly i was
guilty until proven innocent
up until the point that you learned that
you were not going to be in the pirates
of the caribbean franchise any longer
what was your intention with respect to
future pirates movies
the
the last thing that i knew
from
the
um
the the
i say that the power the there's the
producer team there's the creative team
um
and there were many discussions
um
i in fact
had been approached to
take part in writing
mr deb what was your intention with
respect to future pirates movies
aside from what you'd been asked to do
my feeling was that
these characters
should be able to
have their proper
goodbye
as it were
a franchise can only last for so long
and
there's a way to end
a franchise like that and i thought that
the characters
deserve to
to have their
their way out of
to to end the
the franchise on a
on a on a very good note i planned on
continuing i
until it was time to stop
you